mort subite de zacharie miccio 21 ans
semblait inexplicable il était en
excellente santé physique et
affectionnez particulièrement les sports
acrobatiques à l'été 2016
il a sombré dans le lac saint-pierre en
outaouais après avoir effectué un
plongeon qu'ils étaient habitués de
faire j'ai demandé au coroner
comment est-ce que mon petit poisson a
coulé dans l'eau et se noyer
j'avais besoin de la vérité sa mère est
de métro raconte pour la première fois
son histoire à la télévision
à l'époque elle ignorait que dans les
heures précédentes son fils avait
consommé du red bull la coronaire qui a
étudié son dossier est sans équivoque
toute la preuve appuyé le fait que les
boissons énergisantes ont contribué à
une heure et demie et le fait que sa
carri était dans l'eau des lots ya
sombré
il s'est noyé les décès est lié aux
boissons énergisantes sont certainement
des cas extrêmes mais les effets
indésirables liés à ces produits sont
nombreux et bien documenté chez les
jeunes de 12 à 24 ans que ce chercheur a
sondé près de la moitié de ceux qui
avaient consommé des boissons
énergisantes ont affirmé avoir ressenti
un effet indésirable comme des
palpitations des vomissements ou des
convulsions rapporte david ramade
ces études sont parmi les plus récentes
au canada sur la question
ces effets ne seront plus rendues
publiques par santé canada depuis 2013
enquête a découvert que depuis quatre
nouveaux décès ont été signalés aux
autorités ils s'ajoutent aux trois déjà
connu ce produit qui devrait pas être vu
par les enfants mais les adolescents et
malheureusement c'est le grand public
cible c'est ceux qui en boivent le plus
c'est ce qu'ils sont le plus sensibles
aux effets néfastes et en plus souvent
les bois dans un contexte justement
d'activités sportives
c'est très préoccupant c'est préoccupant
on peut pas rester inactif devant des
situations telles que cela interpellé
par nos révélations
la ministre québécoise de la santé oms
visage d'interdire la vente des boissons
énergisantes aux moins de 16 ans c'est
une des options qu'il faut regarder
il y en a probablement d'autres mais
soixante et une qui avait été invoquée
effectivement par notre parti sans
préciser son échéancier québec compte
lancer les travaux sur la question des
boissons énergisantes assez rapidement
la ministre espère obtenir des
recommandations des experts en santé
publique avant les prochaines élections
ici julie tu seras une radio canada
montréal